cbs news has not projected a winner in
four states that's georgia north
carolina arizona and alaska
but we should point out that even if
president trump won those states he
would not be re-elected he doesn't have
the votes
nationally president-elect that's joe
biden
now has 279 electoral votes chief
washington correspondent major garrett
joins us now
to discuss major where to begin we've
got world leaders from all around the
world congratulating joe biden
but yet in the in the republican party
they become mute they're refusing to
acknowledge these results
what is the impact of all of this well
it goes against our history it goes
against good governance and the longer
it goes the deeper it will create
divisions in this country about what
actually happened in this election
and the president and the republicans
who stand with him will have to bear
the responsibility for whatever comes
from that i don't know what that's going
to be
but this is not in concert with the way
we approach
governance in this country it simply
isn't everyone knows all rational
republicans know these lawsuits are
essentially
hearsay meaningless and distractions
period that's all they are
they are delaying the inevitable every
sensible republican on capitol hill
knows that in his or her heart of hearts
and their mute testament and loyalty to
the president
will only serve to encourage him to
resist
what is inevitable the transition of
power and history will judge them
harshly
i think people are aren't really
surprised that donald trump is
responding this way he has said all
along that
it would be very difficult for him to
lose and very difficult to accept the
results but what is a what is the
republican strategy here
well the republicans tell themselves the
following story gail
that only by allowing the president to
go through this process
and exhaust in their terminology all
legal claims even the fanciful ones that
they have put before the courts
currently only that process will
reassure the president
coax him to a concession and bring his
supporters along with him
that is the story they tell themselves
they also told them a story
told themselves a story in the spring
about the president approaching the
coronavirus
as winston churchill with tremendous
optimism leadership and heroism i'll
leave it to them to judge whether or not
that happened but i will
quote churchill in this one sense about
this entire situation we find ourselves
in
you cannot reason with a tiger when your
head is in its mouth
so you know when you're a little kid on
the playground i think junior high
school
they tell you either put up or shut up
so at what point does the trump
administration have to
put up or shut up we keep saying show
evidence and they haven't done so yet
the courts will rule and when the courts
tell them this is as david becker
indicated in that previous piece
affidavits that are based on hearsay
they're not timely they're not relevant
they're not confirmable you have no case
go away
and state legislatures say we're not
going to overwill override the will of
the people
through express through tabulated votes
then it's over we already know it's over
all we're waiting for is someone at the
top of our government to realize that
all right major garrett always good to
see you thank you